Implementing remove lowest this way was nice because we already had these
methods and we could just use them. And this almost reads like a kind of
English now. What's the low score, find the low score, remove the low score.
But these first two steps were kind of repetitive. In this example we had to go
through every item to find what the lowest one was. And then go through them
again to find the index of it. If this were a very long array with millions of
items in it, we wouldn't want to have to go through all of the data twice just
to get the location. We would want to think a little deeper and try to combine
some of these loops. So, what if we had a method, getlowScorePosition, that
would replace the two steps of finding the minimum element and also finding
it's index.